- You guys are (beep)
with me, though, right?
Like, I don't actually
need all this stuff,
this is overkill.
(upbeat music)
- Today we're learning from Michelle Phan.
- I've never put on makeup for myself.
- I have two sisters who
tortured me with makeup.
- I am doing Michelle
Phan's Midnight Luster.
- I am doing 'How to
look like a K-Pop Star'.
- I'm putting on makeup
for a romantic date.
- I chose the wedding tutorial
because, on my wedding day,
my wife spent like hours
doing her hair and makeup.
- This already looks extremely difficult.
- Lightweight brunette brown gel?
- There are so many brushes.
- [Voiceover] Do women
actually own this much makeup?
'Cause that's crazy.
- [Voiceover] Is concealer
like a one size fits all?
- She's making her wider Vietnamese eyes
look pointier like my Korean eyes.
- Like combing my eyebrows,
never done that before.
- Yeah, yeah, this is too, too bright.
- Getting ready for a football game.
That's how I'm gonna make
this gender-normative.
- This is basically exactly
what Michelle Phan was doing.
- Do women spend this
long on just the eyes
or am I just dumb?
- You know what I'm so upset about,
is that Eugene is going
to be so good at this
because he had sisters.
- As long as I'm prettier
than Zach, I'll be okay.
- It's very possible that I've been using
the wrong one the whole time.
- You apply the foundation normally.
That's not a descriptor.
- Next time a friend asks me
to come with her to Sephora
and I'm like really
impatient and getting angry
about how long it looks, I'm going to just
shut the (beep) up
like I get it now, I get it.
- Ahhh, I touched my eyeball with it!
- Oh, I just stabbed my eyeball.
- Poked myself in the eye.
- I don't know why my solution
is to just make it bigger,
but it is.
- Oh yeah! Instantly sexier.
- Beauty is pain, beauty
is pain, beauty is pain...
- Whoa! I broke it.
- Eye torture complete.
Nope, I (beep) it up.
- I've seen videos online where girls
chop off their eyelashes doing this.
- (yelling) Wasn't so bad.
(coughs)
- This isn't right, but it's something.
- Look at me now, Mom.
Everything you wanted.
- Here's your beauty shot.
- Do I like beautiful? Yes!
Did my wife look better
on her wedding day?
Absolutely.
- I just look like a pretty
guy, who could maybe make it
in a K-pop band, that's okay
with lipstick and eye glitter.
- I knew it was like,
something that took an hour,
I didn't think it was something
that made you stressed for an hour.
- I just look like a
confused glittery panda.
- I feel like I could
practice this for years,
and still be terrible at it.
(magical tinkling)
- Thanks, Michelle!
- Your hair's blocking, Eugene.
Your hair? Your h-- Eugene, your hair?
Your hair's in the-- Just don't wanna...
The hair again.
It's really, it's just that,
I don't think you realize
how small my head is, and
how large your hair is?